welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast
today's episode begins with a series of
updates and clarifications related to
previous episodes we talk a little bit
about pro hormones and steroids
we talk a little bit about fashion
advice and of course we talk about olive
oil-based desserts
that's followed by some very impressive
feats of strength and then a research
roundup segment where we talk about
caffeine
napping metabolic adaptation and then
interventions
involving intuitive eating and mindful
eating after that we have an article
discussion segment where we
honestly just kind of gripe about the
sad state of peer-reviewed publishing
and then after that greg has a q a
segment where he answers
a number of different questions about
training finally you may recall from a
previous episode that greg discussed
the spurious link between your
personality type
and the right intermittent fasting
protocol for you
well in today's episode greg plays us
out by educating us about yet another
factor to consider
when thinking about what intermittent
fasting window you might pursue
as always thank you for listening and we
hope you enjoy the show
all right welcome back to the stronger
by science podcast
we are back in the booth to record
another
banger as the kids say uh
season four pushes forward uh for
today's episode i'm joined by a very
special
temporary guest co-host his name is greg
knuckles greg
how are you doing i'm doing well thanks
for having me on how are you doing
i am doing well it's a beautiful day out
there springtime in north carolina
sun shining i love it i had my coffee
this morning it was it was wild i
normally i go drink my coffee in the
morning by a pond in like the nearby
park
and like i live you know in a city it's
not like i'm out in the wilderness
there's a bunch of wildlife today
there's like this hawk that was chilling
there and a bunch of turtles
a bunch of deer came by it was a very
atypical day i don't know what was going
on there
city of oaks baby absolutely those are
uh
all critters one can find in a deciduous
temperate forest yeah it was lovely you
love to see it
yeah okay so good news let's start off
with some good news
i'm going to kick things off uh starting
out
i saw this story an anonymous donor
used a thousand dollars in dogecoin
earnings
to pay adoption fees at a daytona animal
shelter
uh keeping the animal theme going here
so
you love to see it i i get a kick out of
all these stories though because it
the entire concept of dogecoin it just
doesn't seem like real life and yet
people are making
actual wealth and uh apparently doing
some good things with it so that's
always nice to see
yeah it's it's a meme that also happens
to be environmental terrorism
uh but if you can put that towards uh
saving some animals more power to you
yeah i i do hate the uh
everything about the energy costs
associated with uh
mining of cryptocurrency but uh
you know we're gonna try to pretend that
there's good news and that is
part one part two i am on the good news
segment to bring it down
correct uh and you never you never fail
there is nothing i can
do to or there's nothing i can't do to
rain on your sunny disposition
correct uh okay gift point number two i
think this one's gonna win you over
i saw an article headline that
mcdonald's sales
are back to pre-covet levels so yeah
profits uh in the last three months have
jumped almost 40 percent
uh and i'm not usually one to
uh get really personally worked up when
an enormous corporation makes a bunch of
profits
but you know you just love to see
mcdonald's back on top
they're an american fixture and one of
the things that's always gotten under my
skin
is that fitness people completely
disparage mcdonald's almost as if they
have to
it's like kind of a knee-jerk reflex
where
people are like do you like fitness yes
how much
i love fitness so much that i'm going to
pretend mcdonald's isn't absolutely
delicious
when in fact it is uh and you know we
were talking about this
off the air i think that movie by morgan
spurlock
super size me i think that is what made
people start treating mcdonald's as if
it was like
its own class of poison uh which
i don't know mcdonald's is it tastes
really damn good and if you tell me it
doesn't then i
am going to think that you're a liar oh
yeah and i mean like the
the documentary itself was pretty
ridiculous because it's just like hey
i'm going to
go out of my way to not exercise any 5
000 calories a day and guess what a
month later
i gained weight it's not great it's like
no [ __ ] dude
uh and like the thing the barbs that
they throw
at mcdonald's it's like oh man there's
so much fat
there's so much sodium it's like yeah
that's why it [ __ ] tastes good
yeah you know yeah yeah no mcdonald's is
delicious
uh and i i love to see them succeed
now i don't want to be a hypocrite it's
been a while since i had mcdonald's so i
don't want to
now if they want to sponsor the show i
can change that
i could eat mcdonald's every day but uh
but they are not a sponsor of the show
which is
a shame but uh i haven't had it in a
while but
it has a special place in my heart i
i've eaten enough mcdoubles
to uh to satisfy many lifetimes so uh
good to see him back on top what do you
have uh
in the realm of good news this week yeah
so i have some good vaccine news
and i'm not going the direction with
this that you probably
expect me to be well i'm going the
direction you in particular expect me to
go because you can see the outline
but this does not relate to covet at all
it relates to malaria so malaria
still a very serious illness a lot of
people get it per year
uh a lot of people who are either very
young very old
immunocompromised still die of malaria
every year
um and one of the reasons that it's been
such an issue is that it's
i i saw a quote uh in an article that uh
something along the lines of like uh
malaria vaccine trials are where good
ideas go to die
it's just been very very challenging to
come up with an effective
vaccine against malaria and that's
largely because malaria is caused by a
parasite
so you know most of the things that we
have good vaccines for
caused by right are caused by viruses or
bacteria
um and you know vaccine manufacturers
have
a lot of tricks up their sleeves to
figure out how to provoke
an immune response that will help the
body uh
fight off bacterial and viral infections
but yeah parasites are
an entire different beast they're much
more complex they're apparently
way way harder to develop a vaccine for
and there is a vaccine currently out
there but it's not very effective
it's certainly better than nothing but
recent trials show that it's probably
around
55 percent effective uh but there is a
new one coming down the pipe and uh
results from a phase two clinical trial
show that it is about 77 effective
at uh preventing malaria infections
which is absolutely excellent uh so
you know lots of stuff that that
performs well in phase 2 trials doesn't
wind up
making it through phase 3 but currently
it uh
it looks very optimistic very exciting
uh
and i'm definitely hoping that pans out
man
those challenges that you described and
the
efficacy numbers it just makes you so
much more
grateful for the batch of
covet vaccines that are out there like
as disastrous as the pandemic has been
the fact that we were able to get what
like four or five
really viable vaccines out there is that
where we're at now
i think globally it's more than that
yeah it might be because there's
pfizer uh johnson and johnson
astrazeneca which is currently on hold
um everywhere i don't think everywhere
but
a lot of places but yeah i think people
are expecting that it will
get rolled out again yeah uh and i mean
those are just the ones in from kind of
like the anglo world
uh there's also synovacs and sputnik
and oh man i feel like
i feel like there was another one maybe
developed in either brazil
or india uh and i believe cuba
either developed one or is
currently in like late stage trials for
one so there's yeah
i think there's like four that are
getting pretty broad roll out currently
and like
uh at least another four that are out
there yeah
it's just uh man
you know the fact that we within a year
are able to get uh
vaccines out there with the kind of
efficacy numbers that they have is
is pretty remarkable uh all right so
let's move on
past the good news um got some updates
and clarifications actually quite a few
so i'm going to kick things off so i
mentioned
pro hormones on a previous episode i
forget which one to be honest but
we're talking a little bit about pro
hormones and going back and forth about
when they got
banned and when they got taken off the
market and stuff like that
and a quick shout out to dr mike lane a
very strong gentleman good friend of
mine very funny
also very smart he is a professor of
exercise science really knows his stuff
and he's a really solid lifter as well
but but he uh he kind of left me a
voicemail and kind of
jogged my memory about some of the
timeline here and
it encouraged me to revisit the topic
and kind of fill in the timeline so
1990 was the anabolic steroids control
act
that really shook up the recreational
use of anabolic steroids
it's crazy to think of this now you know
greg you and i were
uh one of us is in our 20s the other
very old in our 30s uh this is the first
time i've actually said that i'm in my
30s
uh man i feel really old very quickly
here
uh but anyway our entire lives steroids
have been a very bad thing in america
you know treated as a controlled
substance
just like any other extremely terrible
street drug
and uh it's crazy to think that there
was a time not long ago
where recreational use of anabolic
steroids was a fairly typical thing and
it wasn't
it wasn't treated as a controlled
substance but uh
you know obviously in our lifetimes that
that has very much changed
so uh people still liked to get big
even after steroids were officially
labeled as
uh controlled substances and so uh
then people start putting these designer
steroids uh
on the market and you know they they
weren't
you know technically they weren't
falling under the umbrella of what had
been identified as controlled substances
but they were very much just
uh very specialized designer anabolic
steroids
and so in 2004 notable painter george w
bush
and congress instituted the anabolic
steroid control act of 2004 they banned
over-the-counter
steroid precursors increased a bunch of
penalties and they
kind of added a big list of what is now
at that time considered anabolic
steroids so they're trying to get
a lot of the designer steroids off the
market
now people still enjoyed getting big
believe it or not
and so even though they expanded this
list of what was considered
illegal controlled substances it became
popular for people to start making
what you might call clones or other kind
of like pro hormone
type designer steroids which were
functionally similar to a lot of the
things
on the banned illegal list but
technically
uh you know from a chemical perspective
they were distinct
compounds uh and so when i was really
up to date with what people were doing
in the bodybuilding world from like 2008
to 2010
the ones that everybody was talking
about were h draw
and m draw also known as super drawl
those were the oral pro hormones that
were
all over the market and uh
i don't know much about them to be
honest uh
what i hear is that they're pretty
brutal for your liver
and uh and you know but anyway people
were you could get them like
over just any supplement store over the
counter
uh at that time and uh and those were
kind of the the pro hormones i was
referring to in a previous episode where
all these people like in the
bodybuilding world they were like the
people who were natty
and then there were the people who were
not natty and then there was the like
natty plus pro hormones crowd kind of in
the middle
uh and that's what they were taking and
then in 2014 the designer anabolic
steroid control act
was passed uh and that basically
expanded the list of anabolic steroids
uh and kind of it was like their their
final
attempt to say like okay we made our
first list you got around it we made our
second list you got around it
we're making a very broad list now and
so that was the legislation in 2014 that
really uh really
did a number on the oral pro hormone
market
whatever was left of it after the the
2004 legislation so
it's been a wild ride and you know i
i've seen rick collins talk at a number
of different conferences back when
conferences
uh you know existed and you could go
around the country and go to them
but uh you know he he always says in his
presentations uh people really like
getting big
and they're gonna continue to try to
find ways to do it and so
even after uh all these pro hormones got
uh you know taken off the market or at
least really
more aggressively pursued by by the fda
and related uh
people are still trying to innovate and
put you know new stuff on the market
that that kind of just gets a little bit
out of
the letter of the law and allows them to
sell it so
that is the update related to pro
hormones kind of an updated timeline
there
uh also an update and a clarification
about fashion advice
so a while ago we did a
fireside chat and we answered a lot of
questions about fashion
and we mentioned that we're both pretty
loyal to the george brand
uh george brand carried i think
exclusively by walmart
uh really good when you consider the
design the quality
uh the seemingly impossible prices
it it almost seems like the finished
products are worth less than the raw
materials used to make them well
and and just the amount of drip yeah
honestly
correct uh so yeah i've always been a
george guy and that's not going to
change
but i was in michael's the other day
michael's for those who aren't aware in
america
michael's is a chain of stores that
sells like arts and craft supplies i'm a
crafty guy
i do all sorts of crafts and so i was in
there and i saw these shirts
and i mean they were immaculate really
really well done
uh stylish shirts three for ten dollars
hard to beat that deal for t-shirts so
uh
i revamped my wardrobe and i'm actually
wearing one right now this is a
michael's
oh man and uh i think it's gonna be you
know so i
i am still a george guy because i can
only get my t-shirts at michael's but
i guess i'm i'm more of a george michael
guy now where i do some george i do some
michaels
and so that's my update if you're if
you're trying to stay on the cutting
edge
of fashion then michael's is worth a
visit
it actually got me thinking uh i'm an
industrious guy
i'm an entrepreneur and i've got that
spirit just kind of oozing out of me
i'm thinking i might start making
counterfeited stronger by science
apparel
uh you know the people want it uh you
and lindsey have been dragging your feet
which is ridiculous
so i think i'm gonna start like trexler
apparel llc
and just start counterfeiting completely
unlicensed stronger by science gear so
folks keep an eye out for that how are
you gonna sell that gear
i don't know i'll figure it out do you
know
the login info for our email service
um no okay cool
uh so i had an update and clarification
as well
uh very big mistake on my part and i
apologize in advance
a few episodes back i recommended a
recipe that people should
check out and make for themself if they
have a sweet tooth that they want to
sate
uh it's a recipe for olive oil blondies
from
sola el whaley very good recipe still
strongly recommend that not going back
on that in the least
however in that segment uh my wife
brought this to my attention
i did note that i had not had
other olive oil non-cake
desserts uh and that is incorrect
i have both had and made lemon olive oil
tarts before
um which are exceptional
i forgot about them because the olive
oil flavor doesn't come
through so you use olive oil
in the lemon curd in place of butter uh
just because
due to some food chemistry that i'm not
going to pretend like i understand
the tart citrus flavor just cuts through
uh like olive oil fat better than it
does butter fat
so you get a brighter crisper lemon
flavor
but there there was olive oil in that
dessert it's not a cake
so i did mislead you about that but if
you
tried solas olive oil blondies and you
like them
and you said hey i want some more olive
oil in my life
just google olive oil lemon tart
america's test kitchen has a really
really good recipe for that
it's very simple it's the easiest
citrus tart i've ever made and it's so
good
uh so if you and you know the weather's
warming up at least in the northern
hemisphere uh
you know if you want a good refreshing
warm weather dessert
check out lemon olive oil tarts they're
delicious
good stuff uh moving on has anybody
done anything strong lately yeah yeah a
few people
uh so i'm going to save the best for
last
and people who follow the strength
sports world probably
already know what that's going to be but
i'm going to start with
something that's also absolutely insane
so jackson powell he is a teenage lifter
who we've talked about on the podcast a
few times
very strong overall but exceptionally
strong squatter
recently posted a video of himself
squatting uh 925 pounds or
420 kilos for a double um
in training and i i think he's prepping
for a meat i think he has a meat coming
up
later this month um
but yeah he's 18 years old he's a child
uh he might squat a thousand pounds
before he graduates from high school
it almost seems a sure thing that he's
gonna squat a thousand pounds as a
teenager like he's got at least another
year for that
uh regardless absurdly strong
absolutely incredible very very
impressive
moving on from the uh kern us open
chad pinson unseated uh the great john
hack
uh totaling 996 and a half
kilos or 2197 pounds
in the 198 pound or 90 kilo weight class
to
win that weight class and i believe win
best overall at the meet
as well he also squatted a world record
so
in knee wraps he squatted 400 kilos
at 90 kilos that's 881 pounds for
americans uh and and that's just bonkers
um he he came
three and a half kilos away from
totaling a thousand kilos
uh at a body weight below 200 pounds so
just uh just bonkers [ __ ]
all around uh and congratulations to him
also check out the videos from that meet
uh
chad pinson is outrageously jacked so
also
kudos to him for that uh also
from the current us open uh hunter
henderson
a female lifter competes at 165 pounds
or 75 kilos
she set a world record with a 295 kilo
or 650 pound squat in knee wraps
and uh you should also check out the
video for that by the way
uh we're gonna start posting the videos
in the show notes uh
eric has had access to the videos this
whole time
they are always posted in the outline uh
i've seen the comments saying hey where
are the videos for feats of strength
that is the main host's fault uh for not
including them not the temporary guest
co-host
just so we're clear about that but
anyway check out hunter squat
uh it looked like an opener uh
i mean i don't know what it looks like
when she misses but
she looked like she had at least 675 680
in her
very very impressive lift and
the second to last one i have on my list
i know i'm gonna butcher this name
but uh a i believe russian lifter pavlo
nakanechni uh deadlifted 435 kilos or
959 pounds for a triple in the gym
uh he was lifting equipped i believe he
he has competed in powerlifting but he
primarily competes in strong man now
uh but yeah 9 59 for a triple
very very strong but when checking out
his instagram
that actually wasn't the most impressive
lifting he's done recently
for my money he did a set of rows that
was maybe more impressive than those
deadlifts
uh it was 260 kilos or 573 pounds for
like a reasonably strict set of six
uh so for most people out there
uh there is someone who can do
relatively strict rows with your
deadlift max
and that is both cool and terrifying
uh and then the last thing i have again
if you follow strength sports you knew
this was coming
lasha my boy the georgian god of
weightlifting himself
some videos came out of some training
lifts uh
he snatched 225 kilos and clean and
jerked 270.
i believe both of those are no i i don't
believe
i'm 99.999
sure both of those are the biggest
weightlifting lifts
ever caught on video uh in freedom units
that i believe is 496lbs pounds
for the snatch and 595
for the cleaning jerk uh so he's two and
a half kilos away from going 500 600 in
weightlifting
um which is just bonkers that's insane
he's so strong uh you know
i just want to see him go 500 600 at the
olympics that would be
so nasty yeah that would be cool uh but
you
did not put a video of his lift in the
outline so i
i don't accept any responsibility if
that
doesn't make it into the show notes i
will
add that video to the outline but to be
clear
all of the rest are already in there so
if you don't see at least
four feats of strength videos in the
episode description
send your hate mail to eric trexler
perfect all right so moving on to some
research stuff
i've got a quick research roundup
segment
this week a research roundup
for people who are just joining us for
the first time
uh welcome by the way research roundup
we just look at a few different
uh pieces of research not super deep
dives into them but just kind of
hitting the highlights of some new
research that's come out so
the first study i wanted to talk about
it was called
caffeine use or napping to enhance
repeated sprint performance
after partial sleep deprivation why not
both
a good question indeed so the purpose
here was to compare
three different uh interventions the
idea was
you either take a 20-minute nap or you
have a dose of caffeine five milligrams
per kilogram a pretty uh pretty generous
dose of caffeine there
or the third intervention was a
combination so having caffeine
right before that 20-minute nap
and seeing how those would affect
repeated sprint performance again
after a night of partial sleep
deprivation
and if memory serves i think during the
nights of partial sleep deprivation i
think they got about
four hours of sleep give or take
so that's usually about what they try to
do
with these types of studies so uh
very straightforward study and so the
comparator groups here
uh that they were you know measuring
these different interventions against uh
one was just how well people performed
after a normal night of sleep
and the other was uh partial sleep
deprivation plus a placebo
so they did a really nice job kind of
deciding what
conditions they would do their testing
under
and the results were pretty interesting
so first things first
you might be wondering uh caffeine
before a nap how does that work
because usually caffeine induces
wakefulness
well you can do a caffeine timing
strategy where if the caffeine is
consumed
just before the nap you're really not
going to be getting
a ton you're probably not going to reach
your peak blood levels of caffeine
until after that 20 minute nap is
already over
so you actually can time that pretty
effectively it's not like the moment you
ingest
caffeine you're going to instantly be
awake and alert and unable to nap so
you can time that up perfectly but you
do want to make sure you get that
caffeine dose
uh just before the nap occurs and you
probably want to avoid
i would imagine if you're going to try
that strategy you probably want to avoid
caffeinated gum
as your route of administration because
that does tend to get
into uh circulation a little bit quicker
than
a caffeinated beverage uh or capsule or
something like that
so uh with this study they had nine uh
highly trained
judo athletes who uh underwent all these
different conditions
in a crossover trial and uh the results
were pretty interesting so
napping just to kind of put it uh in a
nutshell
rather than going each outcome one by
one the general finding was that
napping was actually uh a little bit
better than caffeine alone
uh so that was pretty interesting a lot
of people i think would assume that
caffeine
you know because even in the absence of
sleep restriction caffeine does have an
ergogenic effect
uh napping alone was actually a little
bit better than caffeine
alone within this context but as you can
kind of tell by the title
napping plus caffeine took the gold
medal here it was actually
better than either treatment
independently so
i thought this was a really practical
kind of quick simple
to the point study uh i'm sure we've all
found ourselves there at one time or
another where
we're pretty sleep deprived but we don't
want to skip the workout we're trying to
think
what should i do here should i just try
to caffeinate my way through it maybe
take a nap
and as the title implies why not both it
looks like both can be
a pretty good combined strategy
now moving on to another study
i'm going to save the metabolic
adaptation one for for last i'm going to
go out of order with the
the outline here uh the next one i want
to cover
is the title is the influence of mindful
eating and or
intuitive eating approaches on dietary
intake
a systematic review now when i talk
about this study
i want to be very clear that i'm not
trying to
like attack a straw man argument here
i think a lot of people when they see
that that title
you know this study was looking at how
intuitive eating or mindful eating
specifically impact dietary intake so
the amount of food
taken in and the quality of food taken
in and so a lot of people right off the
bat would say like
dude like nobody's saying that intuitive
eating or mindful eating are going to
change
your intakes like they're not marketed
as
you know highly efficacious weight loss
strategies to lower your calorie intake
necessarily
uh in most applications they're treated
as a pretty weight neutral approach
that doesn't uh insist upon lowering
your calorie intake or
or changing it in any direction so uh i
have seen
some people suggesting that intuitive
eating or mindful eating
are efficacious within that context uh
but certainly
i think a lot of people are going to be
turned off just by the title alone
feeling that they're kind of
attacking a straw man argument there
but you know whenever we have uh a
strategy like mindful eating or
intuitive eating i think there's a
tendency for
it to become popular uh and it certainly
has
uh both of those strategies have become
uh relatively popular
and when we see this strategy it becomes
popular
and i think it also kind of represents
something that people feel strongly
about
which is kind of getting away from the
ultra restrictive diet culture
i think it it can lead to a level of
enthusiasm
where people might start to kind of use
the transitive property and say okay
intuitive eating and mindful eating are
good for this
therefore let's assume that they're just
a pretty kick-ass intervention for
all things i might want to do with them
so some people have been kind of
implying that these are good strategies
for reducing calorie intake or
drastically altering
uh quality of food intake and things
like that so i think that's what the
researchers were really trying to get at
here um now they looked at
uh so i have a question sure
i don't uh follow the nutrition world
closely which is to say at all uh
but whenever i see intuitive eating pop
up
in my instagram timeline uh
when it intrudes on the dog and meme
content that i'm trying to consume on
the platform
uh i do often see
people talk about it uh
either with the slant of it's good for
weight loss
or it's good for weight loss maintenance
like that that's the frame that i
always see it discussed in so like
what do people promote it for
yeah like just you you you've
addressed that you're not trying to
address that straw man
but from what i've seen what you're
saying is a straw man
is the only frame i've ever seen it in
so what is
the quote-unquote correct frame to
discuss intuitive eating
so like i acknowledge that i do see that
but i i think i'm trying to be extra
charitable perhaps
um but but no you do see people saying
like oh this is a great
strategy specifically for weight loss
but generally speaking
uh these interventions are treated as
pretty weight neutral approaches
uh and so like there was a good uh
review by clifford and colleagues
no yeah like i get that they're supposed
to be weight neutral but like
theoretically if you're using them as an
intervention
yeah they're supposed to do something
good for you right yeah so like what
what positive thing are they supposed to
do yeah so
clifford and colleagues a different
study okay they found that
uh intuitive eating and mindful eating
type interventions
enhance psychological outcomes for folks
uh
you know lower depressive symptoms
uh improve disordered eating patterns uh
improve
self self-esteem uh improved emotional
well-being
usually what you're trying to do with
these types of interventions is
specifically
uh enhance one's relationship with food
and really kind of get out of that
cluster
of negative affect uh
depressive symptoms anxiety related to
food how that ties into body image
this is more of an intervention that
aims to alleviate some of the
psychological
distress associated with disordered
eating habits
or uh perspectives toward eating that
fall under that umbrella
gotcha gotcha yeah so so a lot of times
you see
mindful eating and intuitive eating as
things that are supposed to help people
get back in touch
with their satiety cues uh and
break away from you know really
obsessive habits related to
uh strict control disordered eating
habits
things like that so yeah the idea is to
get more in touch with satiety cues be
more mindful of your meal experience
it can be helpful in a variety of
different contexts for people who
struggle with negative body image
disordered
eating habits binge eating habits and
eating habits that are completely
disconnected from physiological hunger
okay so so that's what it's for uh
you know if you ask anyone who uses it
in a
clinical setting but if you ask it
anybody who
like markets it in an attractive
fitness setting of like hey i've got a
cool thing for you on instagram
that's where you see a lot of it is like
ah this is a
very efficacious weight loss program i
see
yeah yeah okay that makes sense yeah so
uh
in in this review they looked at a total
of 13 studies
and cutting straight to the point there
was little evidence to suggest that
mindful eating or
intuitive eating really influence
energy intake or diet quality so
uh the people who promote this uh
in in the way that you have interacted
with on the internet
uh are probably clear i haven't
interacted with it at all
uh i'm like david attenborough yeah uh
observing diet culture in its natural
habitat like me and my hawk this morning
yeah yeah
i i look but don't touch you know yeah
so so yeah the people who are pushing
these interventions
in that context are probably getting a
little ahead of themselves
maybe they're the innovators that are
ahead of the science uh
that has happened before but the science
so far has not caught up with their
marketing
uh and who knows if it will
uh but again i just want to reiterate
that that
doesn't mean that there's no place for
mindful eating
interventions or intuitive eating
interventions like i said
there's good research indicating that
these interventions can enhance
psychological outcomes reduce depressive
symptoms reduce
disordered eating patterns improve
self-esteem improve emotional well-being
and help people get back in touch with
being present and mindful during their
eating
and really adhering to their
physiological satiety cues
uh in a much more connected way so there
can be some really positive things here
but you know when we look at this
literature we don't see
significant uh consistent changes in
energy intake diet quality
we don't see uh significant changes in
body weight blood pressure blood glucose
cholesterol
so it has a place it can be an
efficacious intervention but only for
the things that it's really targeting
and this is uh not inherently
a weight loss strategy uh so
the final thing i wanted to cover in the
research roundup relates to
the old hobby horse metabolic adaptation
uh
so i wrote an article for stronger by
science on the website that's
a million pages long it's the first ever
million page article
uh it is very very long and it covers a
lot
about adaptive thermogenesis and
metabolic adaptation and
things like that and so whenever a new
paper comes out on the topic
people often reach out to me they send
it to me and they say what do you think
about this
and so this was one of those cases the
title of the paper was
does adaptive thermogenesis occur after
weight loss in adults
a systematic review and some people
encouraged me to write about this for
mass but i
opted not to and the reason
was uh greg i'm sure you can relate to
this
a lot goes into selecting what article
you want to choose for mass
you know you you want to make sure that
you're choosing an article that is going
to be highly beneficial to readers
with some good practical applications
and so when i looked through this
particular paper
it was very technical very nuanced and
when i look at the takeaways that i got
from the paper
it they weren't takeaways to help a
trainer
do a better job with their clients they
weren't takeaways to help a dieter have
more success
they were takeaways for how a researcher
ought to design the next study on
metabolic adaptation
and so i didn't want to take our our
poor readers through this
ultra nuanced look at the literature
ultimately to say uh
i hope the researchers account for this
stuff in the future i didn't think that
that was enough of a payoff
and as you often say the the juice was
not worth
the squeeze uh for a mass article but
quickly looking at it uh you know i do
want to at least give an answer to the
people who sent this to me and wanted my
feedback on it so
uh looking through this paper there are
some areas of agreement uh
where i definitely agree with the
perspective of the
researchers who wrote this paper first
of all this literature is very very
nuanced that's something that we
definitely agree on
number two energy balance uh acute
energy balance
matters in a big way so when you're
looking at metabolic adaptation
it matters if you're uh measuring people
who are
in negative energy balance at the time
of measurement or positive or
or neutral energy balance that's a huge
consideration
that alters the measurement in a big way
number three
uh i believe i agree with the authors i
i guess i should say i believe they
agree with me that
metabolic adaptation uh is observed
during active weight loss
uh but it does tend to be smaller uh
when
energy balance is restored and that's
specifically when we're looking at
resting energy expenditure we could see
a pretty big
adaptive drop during active weight loss
and negative energy balance
but once that individual's weight stable
and back in energy balance
that deficit in the resting component of
energy expenditure
is uh largely closed it tends to be a
lot closer to predicted
once energy balance is restored uh
number four the resting metabolic rate
component uh when it comes to metabolic
adaptation
is less impactful than when we look at
something like non-exercise activity
thermogenesis or
total daily energy expenditure number
five
measuring individual organ mass is great
if you have the ability so these
researchers pointed out that
some of the studies instead of just
looking at predicted metabolic rate
based on total fat free mass or total
lean mass
they measured body comp via mri and so
they were able to go in and say well
the resting metabolic rate the metabolic
activity of a kidney
is different than that of a heart that
which is different than that of a liver
so they could actually calculate based
on organ size those tissue
specific metabolic rates which is really
great if you could do it
takes a lot of work and a lot of money
and a lot of time but but if you can
if you can do it i agree with the the
authors of this review
that's a really nice thing that enhances
your predictive ability
number six i agree with them that
metabolic adaptation is not
an insurmountable barrier to weight loss
or the maintenance of weight loss it is
uh it induces a little friction
but if if planned for you know it can
absolutely
be overcome and attenuated and
circumvented
and number seven uh metabolic adaptation
is not the primary contributor
driving weight regain uh it doesn't help
you know it you would like your energy
expenditure to be higher
if you're trying to prevent weight
regain but i think there are far more
impactful things at play and when we
look at uh
research that actually does try to use
regression to predict
in our sample what was driving weight
regain
it's usually not a reduction in resting
energy expenditure
uh you know i think a reduction in
non-exercise activity probably
contributes but
is often harder to measure than resting
energy expenditure
i think reductions in fat free mass
can lead to some pretty excessive hunger
after the weight loss period and during
the weight loss period
there's a lot of good research by dulu
and colleagues looking at the effect of
deficits in fat free mass and how they
drive
specifically appetite during and after a
weight loss attempt so
uh and then there's all the
psychological factors that go along with
trying to maintain these behavioral
changes for
for the long term uh and of course the
psychological factors of
you know if you've really been
restricting food for a long time
your psychology can go nuts i i've
talked to people
this is honest it's probably not going
to sound
true but it is some people late in a
contest prep when they're getting really
lean
and they're in the deepest throws of
metabolic adaptation
and they've been restricting food for a
very long time they're on very low
calories
they will start to hoard kitchen
gear so like people will go and buy
kitchen appliances that they can't even
really make use of yet because they're
just like oh dude
in six weeks i'm gonna eat so much food
and i have 300 recipes i'm gonna try
i've actually heard of people gathering
up kitchen gadgets in preparation for
when they're gonna be able
to explore all these new recipes again
so there's some weird psychological
stuff that goes on with weight loss
you're gonna need to cut this from the
final episode
why is that well because if lindsay
hears this
she will never let me embark on my
eventual
road to the stage because we don't have
room for more kitchen gadgets
no you don't that was that's an ongoing
debate
uh within your household and i i think i
think lindsay's right you already have
too many kitchen gadgets
i really need a food dehydrator that
yeah you you can get that
okay uh now there were some areas of
disagreement those were kind of the
the big highlights of the paper that i
could definitely get on board with
um a small point that i would bring up
they were kind of
uh simultaneously making a couple points
which is
uh accounting for organ tissue has a
huge
impact on minimizing the importance of
what is perceived to be metabolic
adaptation but at the same time
they're saying after the active weight
loss period metabolic adaptation totally
goes away
and they never really in my opinion tied
together
how that works it seems like they were
kind of
pinning it on these two different things
but
if you're losing a great deal of organ
mass during the diet
and then stabilizing a neutral energy
balance and we're saying that the loss
of that organ mass is a big contributor
to what we think
is this adaptive drop uh
i mean i i don't see that organ mass
being promptly regained
in a post weight loss weight neutral
state
so i that was one thing a very minor
point that i i think
warranted a little additional
clarification i mean i think it depends
on how you're defining metabolic
adaptation
well yes because if you're defining it
as
like hey do all of my tissues still
uh burn through calories per unit of
mass at the same rate they did before
then like you know their point is well
taken you lose organ mass
but per unit of mass those organs are
still burning through calories at the
same rate
no metabolic adaptation but if you're
defining it as like
calories per pound of body weight or
calories per pound of total lean mass
but now organ mass has dropped off a lot
and now maybe it's like
a smaller total proportion of lean mass
like your
you know global pool of lean mass might
be burning
fewer calories per pound now uh so you
would say
oh there is metabolic adaptation so i it
to me it just seems like a a matter of
how one is defining terms
yeah well so the the two points that
they're kind of simultaneously making
in different kind of areas of the paper
one is like oh this metabolic adaptation
the
difference between predicted and actual
resting energy expenditure
it's an artifact of us not accounting
for that loss
of organ mass that's why we have this
discrepancy between measured and
predicted
uh to some extent but then saying well
after the act of weight loss if you just
stay at your weight reduced state
eventually that that gap will clear
itself up
i don't see i i don't expect that you
would have
substantial kind of rebound gains of
those organ tissues
when settling at that body weight so i
don't understand how those two work
in unison and i you know i certainly
don't set out to mis
willfully misinterpret uh their
statements or the points of the article
so
perhaps i just missed it but it seemed
like those were two things that
in and of them like independently i
think both are good points
but when you put them together as like a
unified model of how we're
over predicting it but then you know it
kind of levels out over time i wasn't
really certain how they put those two
things together
uh but but that was a very minor point
that i don't want to dwell on
too much because i think there's bigger
points to to discuss
uh so the the bigger points
first of all uh viewing metabolic
adaptation as kind of a dichotomous
outcome like
it either is present or not present i
think in some cases
they kind of fell into that and they're
like oh well
it was present but it is no longer
therefore
boom metabolic adaptation vanished over
time
and in reality it was like there was you
know
200 calories of metabolic adaptation but
it dropped to 175
and was no longer significant and
therefore the adaptation's gone and it's
like well no that was a
very minor partial attenuation not a
complete disappearance
but if you're basing it on the p-values
it went from
existing to non-existing that was a
major limitation that i saw in a few
instances throughout the paper
uh and you know
again in some cases uh
you know we're kind of viewing this
small attenuation as a complete blunting
uh and treating metabolic adaptation as
if it was just kind of like a
measurement error
uh and i i just didn't think that they
really were looking at the magnitudes of
the effects and kind of interpreting
them with the
degree of nuance you would want to apply
to those things so
a few examples to kind of demonstrate
what i'm getting at here
in concrete terms so they looked at a
paper
uh by carl in 2016.
um and so you know this was an
instance where they're like okay well
after uh
weight maintenance the metabolic
adaptation goes away
so at the end of the active weight loss
phase uh
resting metabolic rate was 6.5 percent
lower than baseline
and then at the end of the next phase
the weight maintenance phase
measured measured uh resting metabolic
rate
was 6.2 percent lower than baseline
so uh they lost all this weight and then
they
had a weight maintenance period uh 6.5
below baseline during phase two and that
at that point they're saying yes
metabolic adaptation is present very bad
thing
and then after weight maintenance it's
still 6.2 percent lower than baseline
and they're saying oh yeah it's not
significant uh you know
so no more metabolic adaptation they
were a very similar weight and their
resting metabolic rate was very similar
so treating that as
metabolic adaptation going away i just
don't think there's much of a leg to
stand on there
another one that got me so there was a
study by marlatt
in 2017 and it was the only study
looking at total daily energy
expenditure not resting metabolic rate
the only one looking at total daily
energy expenditure that didn't report
significant metabolic adaptation
now this was a two-year follow-up from a
study by
ravusen in 2015. uh
so in the original study it was like
this uh
24-month weight loss intervention uh
and so the calorie restricted group in
this original study they lost like
all their weight pretty much in the
first six months
huge drop in the first six months then
another little drop from six months to
12 months
and then from 12 to 24 the intervention
continued
but they actually had a slight weight
regain very very minor
but basically they lost a bunch of
weight about 8 kilograms and maintained
it from month 12 to month 24
approximately maintained it now if you
look at month 12 when they were really
at their lowest weight
during this weight loss attempt uh there
was like
definitely metabolic adaptation in this
original study
so total daily energy expenditure was
250 calories below what it was predicted
to be
now in that period from month 12 to
month 24 when they were effectively
doing weight maintenance
body weight uh actually increased a
little bit during that time
and they're still trying to maintain
their typical behaviors that induce the
weight loss
that gap between uh measured and
predicted total energy expenditure
again at month 12 it was like minus 250.
at month 24 it was like
minus 240. uh that persisted uh
period and both of them were
statistically significant p
less than .01 both of those instances
there was metabolic adaptation now
what they argue in the follow-up paper
was that after a maintenance period
the metabolic adaptation effectively
goes away
but there's two big problems with that
uh so
first of all they gained a substantial
amount of weight in that follow-up
period
so it's quite likely that they are being
measured
in positive energy balance which is a
pretty big consideration to keep in mind
but the more important thing is that
total daily energy expenditure was
measured with different methodology and
so like
that's a huge deal and so like if you
want to know within that study
if the metabolic adaptation went away
during weight maintenance
look from month 12 to 24. everything was
measured the same way
it was a continuous intervention and
during that period of
actual slight weight regain the
metabolic adaptation persisted there
when they looked in the follow-up study
it was gone but they were measuring
total daily energy expenditure with a
completely different method
uh and that is a huge deal so i mean
like i used to do
uh body comp testing right and so we
would
do put somebody on the dexa walk them
about
40 yards down the hallway and put them
in the bod pod
and what do you know their body fat went
up two percent
the the conclusion there is not that
that is a hell of a hallway
that somehow puts two percent body fat
on you when you walk down it
the conclusion is these two different
methodologies are not similar enough
that we can interpret the change from
one to the other
as a longitudinal change over time with
perfect precision
so uh that was another one that kind of
jumped out to me and then my
final one i want to get back to the
organ thing
so there's a study by bosey westfall
in 2009. i just want to comment okay
i love it when you dichotomize a
continuous
outcome i think that's so cool it's best
practice
it makes things perfectly clear and
interpretable to everyone
uh and i don't see any problem with it
whatsoever
perfect uh so this no so i mean
that's one of my little hobby horses
because uh
like the same the same like debate
took place with uh hypertrophy research
um you know and you'll still see people
make claims like
oh it takes uh eight weeks of training
for hypertrophy to occur
it's like no like most studies
fail to detect statistically significant
hypertrophy within
or prior to eight weeks it's not like
you weren't growing and then
two months after you start training boom
jacked
like you just don't have the measurement
precision to pick up
on the gradation so like you know it
takes a while for
enough hypertrophy to occur for it to be
reliably measurable
uh but yeah like i'll see
i'll i'll still see that repeated in the
literature
all the time like yeah nah like you you
need eight weeks or whatever and
it's like no like that's that's not how
it works this is a continuous outcome
uh and based on the precision of the
measurements and the statistical power
of the studies like
you just don't have the power to detect
it prior to that point like
yeah but it's not like it's not
occurring yeah
the hypertrophy one's a good example
because i mean that's in all the
textbooks too
it's like hypertrophy doesn't begin
until eight weeks
is kind of how it's often written there
and it's like well that's
statistically significant hypertrophy is
not detectable with current methods
until you've accumulated about eight
weeks worth of hypertrophy
yeah but like if you had a study with
like 2 000 subjects and you were using
mri
it's probably detectable in like a week
and a half yes yeah
yeah with typical sample sizes yeah
uh anyway so this this last example here
bosey westfall 2009. so uh
you know kind of one of the implications
or you know i've seen a lot of chatter
about this paper and they're like oh
dude
if you account for organ tissue like
metabolic adaptation is just measurement
error
like if you account for the organ tissue
it goes away fully explains it
this is a myth uh now when you look at
the study by bosey westfall after weight
loss uh
50 of the drop in resting energy
expenditure
was explained by losses in fat free mass
and fat mass the other 50
was this kind of unexplained adaptive
drop in energy expenditure so 50
explainable
from changes in body mass 50 unexplained
uh what they found was after you
consider the weight of the individual
organs
the amount that was explained by changes
in body composition
went from 50 to 60
and so then the unexplained metabolic
adaptation component
dropped from 50 percent to 40 percent
uh so again i i don't think the authors
necessarily misinterpreted that but
uh i think a lot of people when they
kind of looked over the abstract saw the
chatter about it they said oh god if you
account for organ mass
metabolic adaptation is a total myth
it's a measurement error it's an
artifact
uh but it's not it's just we can enhance
our precision
of what the predicted energy expenditure
ought to be
if we can account for it with with
greater precision account for those
organ weights
so uh in conclusion you look like you're
about to say something yeah i mean also
that's uh you know that's a 10
increase in variance explained i'm
assuming
you know you're putting another variable
in a multiple regression model
uh and so this is a straw man
i'm not claiming that the all that uh
bosey westfall
did this like i do think including
changes in organ mass
you know a priori that's probably a
decision that was made and i
absolutely think that's a justifiable
decision but if you added like
shoe size to a multiple regression model
you will explain
more variation than if you didn't uh
like that's how it works just just
plugging more variables in
will increase the amount of variance
explained uh
and in a situation like this you know
if you're already explaining 50 just
based on
uh changes in fat free mass and fat mass
if you went from explaining 50
of the variance to like 85 then i'd say
like okay cool
like you know 15 maybe that's
measurement error
day-to-day variability whatever but when
you're going from 50
to 60 that's a sh that's a ton of
variance that's still unexplained
exactly yeah and so the takeaway from
that study is not like oh wow
uh turns out metabolic adaptation is
just measurement error
it's oh we can get a more precise
estimate of it if we account for organ
mass
which i fully agree with so um yeah
a lot of the chatter surrounding uh this
study was like
did you know that metabolic adaptation
like kind of maybe doesn't happen and
even if it does
you can fully explain it by changes in
organ mass and then even if it does
it goes away over time you can see how
if we treat metabolic adaptation as a
dichotomous variable
if we look specifically at resting
energy expenditure rather than total
energy expenditure which
incorporates non-exercise activity which
is by far the most
impacted aspect of energy expenditure
if we start making this kind of series
of reductions and simplifications we can
work our way to some of those
conclusions
but ultimately they are in my opinion
erroneous conclusions uh
i think the the value from this paper
which was well done it was it was a
nuanced
review of this literature uh the real
conclusions
are for researchers moving forward
if you're going to study this what do
you need to do you need to measure
people and energy balance to the best of
your ability
you need to when possible look at total
energy expenditure rather than just
resting energy expenditure
if you have the ability accounting for
organ mass is a really fantastic thing
to do so
i think this is a very valuable paper
but i do think it's one of those
instances where the value got
lost by a lot of readers and the chatter
was a little bit
overly reductionist and one final
parting comment about this
which was my first response before i
looked into the oregon mass stuff
i was thinking so what if what if
accounting for
a loss of organ mass what if that
explained away
all of metabolic adaptation
and i was like well what the hell do i
tell a client
because it's like oh damn i can't eat
anything i'm hungry as hell
my energy expenditure has dropped a lot
i'm in a really bad spot here because i
want to keep losing weight but
i can't keep losing weight on the
calories that i'm comfortable with and i
have to keep on cutting because my
energy expenditure is low
am i supposed to look at them and say oh
don't worry it's because your kidneys
are smaller
does that fix it like that's not a from
a practical perspective that's not
helpful in any way if we just tell
somebody like oh hey by the way
all your organs are going to shrink and
it's going to suck that's not
practically any
less shitty than just saying like yeah
for some unexplained reason your your
energy expenditure is gonna drop you
know
i don't know that that's true like so i
i feel like if i
went back 10 15 years to
when i didn't know anything about
physiology
i i would feel like
you know almost like the i personally
want to know everything that's happening
with anything that i do
like i don't like having an unanswered
questions
and so i would so okay like
i'm in i'm in a deficit uh my energy
expenditure is clearly dropping what
used to be
sufficiently low calories to lose weight
no longer is
um and you know it feels like the
decrease in energy expenditure is
disproportionate to the amount of weight
that i've lost
i could see myself like going online and
being like ah
what's happening uh in i feel like if i
came across the concept
of metabolic adaptation or you know if
we're talking 10
15 years ago that's kind of like the
heyday of starvation mode and metabolic
damage and all of that stuff
i i would see myself potentially
thinking like
oh something pathological is happening
you know like
yeah the tissues of my body that are
supposed to be
you know working at x-rate are now
working at like 80
of the capacity they should be able to
work at
and i don't know anything but that seems
bad
you know that seems like something
negative is happening
uh but if it could be explained to me
like hey you're losing weight
you're mostly losing fat maybe you're
losing a little muscle
but you know you simply don't need as
big of a liver or as big of kidneys
to support a smaller body those are very
metabolically active tissues
you're losing some mass from that and
that is
decreasing your energy expenditure by
quite a bit all of your organs are still
working
exactly as they're supposed to uh
there's just less of them
i feel like that would give someone like
me peace of mind
yeah i could see that um especially if
we're setting up a dichotomy where there
either
is this organ related answer or there is
no answer
you know um but my perspective perhaps
i'm too close to this literature
i have found a lot of the stuff that
uh like rose and bomb and label like
what they explain in their 2010 review
to be very intuitive very comprehensive
explanations of what's going on in a
non-pathology non-pathological
presentation
so so from my perspective if i'm saying
like oh it's not that you have a drop in
leptin that's impacting these various
uh aspects of energy metabolism
it's instead that you have a drop in
organ mass that's affecting
metabolism perhaps for some people
that's a little bit more tangible and
can give a little more peace of mind but
at the end of the day in terms of the
practical application of what you do
with that information
i'm not sure if it necessarily gives us
any additional avenue to pursue there so
i mean i'm all for getting better
understandings of
of you know how we explain these drops
in energy expenditure and like i said
overall i think it's a valuable paper
and i i think it's uh i i think they had
some really good points and some good
nuance to it
uh but but i did think it was kind of
funny that uh
you know the the kind of uh
takeaway that a lot of people were
getting at is like oh it's totally fine
it's just that you lose organ mass and
you can't do anything about it and your
energy expenditure is low
because a lot of a lot of the messages i
get from people who are worried about
metabolic adaptation
it's just how do i get more calories
you know and so it's not going to do
much for that crowd
but but for the very uh curious crowd uh
yeah anything that we can add that
explains a little bit more of it i think
is a positive thing
no yeah i think that we uh i think that
our audience and the people that we
directly interact with
probably aren't perfectly representative
of
the general fitness industry like i i
think that
uh you know i think most people
who are in our audience are probably the
people who are
more just kind of like results oriented
and realize like hey
i'm going to go into a deficit it's not
going to be particularly pleasant
i'm going to have to eat less and less
and less and like that's fine but i do
think i mean like i mentioned uh
not all that long ago you'd see people
talking about like quote unquote
mode all the time like that is something
that
you know you don't see people talking
about
in our niche of the fitness industry
much at all anymore
but like people in the broader fitness
industry uh
like that idea still has a lot of
purchase
yeah yeah and a lot of people who kind
of have this
impression that something's wrong with
them you know something that needs
fixing yeah
which of course creates this kind of
opening for people to fill that and say
oh well i actually have what you need
and i'm going to market that i can cure
you of your ailment
so yeah i'm definitely with you on that
uh
but you know while we're arguing and
getting contentious
this is a good opportunity to shift to
the next part of the outline here
and i guess probably just address the
most controversial stronger by sent
by science content of all time i kind of
wanted to open the door for you to
i guess apologize or clear the air for
the controversial content you've been
putting out
what content the study list
oh yeah um
oh man yeah this one uh this one kills
me because
so okay uh there is a
page on stronger by science uh i think
the url is stronger by science.com
studies hyphen archive uh and basically
so uh i used to do
a monthly journal sweep for mass so we
have a list of
uh it was about 120 journals i think now
it's up to about 145
that we would go through every month and
just pull out all of the studies
that uh you know we thought
there was any chance whatsoever we might
want to review for mass
and also that you know i felt that there
was any chance whatsoever
maybe uh i'd want to write about for
stronger by science or
you know these days that we might want
to talk about on the podcast so
it's a kind of broad net um
but also i thought it was a good
resource to put out in the world
because the thing is like the journal
sweep takes a shitload of time
uh if i'm really scooting maybe like 10
to 12 hours
uh more realistically since i
start uh yearning for the sweet embrace
of death midway through
yeah you know i'd lose some productivity
and it would take like
maybe 16 18 hours uh so
you know a lot of work and a lot of
people are
are interested in research and they want
to know what's coming out uh so i
figured like hey
i'm already doing this i want to save
people time
they can just use the journal sweep i'm
already doing
so they won't have to do this [ __ ]
for themselves
uh you know i'll just put it on a page
on the website
link out to some google docs that that
have uh
the the studies i pulled out for this
month and also all of the past journal
sweeps so
you know if someone wants to save some
time and spend
45 minutes scrolling through a list of
three 400 studies instead of
three work days scrolling through uh
150 journals like cool they can do that
and to be clear i don't do the journal
sweep anymore um
kedrick kwon and colby souza do it these
days uh but i i did that for
several years and hated every minute of
it so they do a great job by the way
yeah and they do
exactly what we ask them to do yeah they
they do an excellent job
um yeah so you know figured hey
this is this is a nice thing that i can
do uh
save people time put this out there uh
almost every month at least one person
gets really ass mad about it people hate
it
uh people are very angry that we're
doing this no like most people love it
like that
that page gets a lot of traffic uh
almost
every time i pull up the spreadsheets to
update them
with the most recent months like i see
several people on the spreadsheets like
they get a lot of use um i do think that
they're
a resource that a lot of people who
create content in our space use
and if you do create content in the
evidence-based fitness world
avail yourself of that resource it's
free and always will be
um but yeah so i think most people like
it but there is a very
vocal minority that just [ __ ] hates
it
um and uh yeah i
i don't know how to elaborate that much
no but it's just uh i
i just get a kick out of it every single
month somebody is very angry
specifically at you
and it and it runs the gamut so uh
you know some people will be like oh
there's 400 studies on this list
who could possibly find the time to go
through all of them
and then there will also be like oh i
have this hyper specific
research niche and i looked through and
uh
you know you included five of the
studies
in my little niche that i'm interested
in on your list but there were in fact
two more that i think were cool that
were not on your list you [ __ ]
charlatan
uh yeah that was the one that got me the
the
most was somebody indicating that
somehow this was like an intellectually
dishonest enterprise that you were
running and it's like
dude it's just studies that i think i
might want to use oh yeah
so uh this most recent month someone
what phrase did they use like half a
dozen times uh
it lent itself to catch penny works
which
i didn't even know that word yeah
neither did i i assumed it wasn't good i
think it's british
uh but but basically it's like click
bait
so you know if if uh you know
someone just wants to look look for
resources to put out the
shallowest content possible to make a
quick buck
um and like in fitness you don't need
studies for that
yeah yeah so one that's ridiculous like
if someone wanted to just like
cherry-pick some [ __ ] to like make a
point and sell an ebook
that's gonna take you about five minutes
on pubmed yeah uh
scrolling through 400 studies per month
for several months until you find the
studies you want
not particularly efficient no uh and two
like i never claim that it's a list of
every fitness study
that has ever existed uh
don't don't claim that it's systematic
don't claim that it's comprehensive
it's a list that i just that i find
useful that i think other people will
find useful but
yeah boy oh boy people are mad about it
no i mean
the basic uh approach to all of the
criticisms of the page is like
imagine if you went to review a
world-class
pizza restaurant and your review is just
like you know what honestly
i was in the mood for cheeseburgers and
that pizza
was not a cheeseburger so i hated it
uh okay but i did have some actual
controversial stuff
that i wanted to discuss in a little
article review segment
uh very very brief here just stuff that
i
am genuinely tickled by so
two things that uh unfortunately are
covid related
uh but it is the magnet for
shoddy stuff these days so uh
there was a paper floating around
uh you actually encountered it in the
wild i did yeah but yeah there's a paper
floating around
it was in a pubmed index journal which
means if you were arguing about this you
could give the pubmed link
to this study by number one global
publisher
elsevier yeah and so the the general
vibe
of the article it was about mask wearing
and it was like
listen man if you wear a mask very
dangerous a lot of bad things will
happen
uh bad for your health very scary stuff
probably shouldn't be wearing a mask is
kind of the general
the general vibe i got from a brief skim
uh is
is that uncharitable is that pretty much
yeah
that it would uh i think what they were
arguing basically was that it would
cause uh respiratory
acidosis which would therefore
cause heart disease and cancer and
people die yeah so here's the deal uh
it was shoddy and bad and stupid
uh wearing a mask uh for a healthy
individual
is not going to do all those scary
things uh
and so generally speaking the sales
pitch
for the existence of peer-reviewed
journals is like listen
the general public doesn't have the
skills the tools
necessary to go through these studies
and determine what is good
good scholarship and rigorous work
uh with robust conclusions it's they
don't have the tools and skills required
to separate that
from you know they can't distinguish the
good from the bad so we have to do that
for them
we we will take that upon ourselves we
will have this rigorous peer review
process
uh experts will critically and very uh
enthusiastically and aggressively go
through this material to make sure that
it is
very good scholarship if it is we'll
publish it and you know
then people can look at that and say
okay this got through peer review this
is going to be some good stuff
uh and then even the people out there
who do have the skills uh
necessary to discern good scholarship
from bad
might might not have the time to you
know open every paper
uh and just say i'm gonna start from
square one here and do a thorough review
you know
peer review that stamp of approval is
theoretically supposed to mean something
uh but the growing trend that i'm seeing
in other fields
which is i'm starting to see at some in
ours is that
journals are just publishing stuff that
is objectively stupid
such that the lay public knows it's
stupid
and then just goes on twitter and says
like hey
this is very stupid and then the
journals have to say like ah
yeah yeah you're right that's pretty
stupid and then they have to retract it
uh so i've seen a
i've seen this happening a lot in other
fields
but basically the trajectory that this
paper took was like
it was very bad and people who are not
experts in the area could tell that very
easily
and then people with expertise in the
area could also verify yes this is very
dumb
but the reason it's elsevier said that
they're going to retract it but
i think the main reason they're going to
retract it is because the author claimed
to be affiliated with a university that
they're not affiliated with
uh and so the university was like please
stop sending us hate mail
we do not employ this person they do not
work for us despite what they say
uh and so elsevier that's very easy
grounds for retracting a paper
uh but honestly i don't know if there
wasn't
an untrue affiliation listed i don't
know if it actually would have gotten
retracted
it's hard to say yeah i mean do we want
to talk about
the paper in a little bit more detail so
it won't sound like we're just
taking random pot shots at it uh
not i mean do you want to go into it i
mean yeah i i'll
i'll be quick sure so uh the thing to
note is that the study was published in
a journal called medical hypotheses
uh and medical hypotheses does not work
the same way most journals work
so in most journals you'll come across
uh you know cross-sectional research
where you collect
data on something and uh you know look
for associations or they'll publish
uh narrative reviews which are review
articles they don't do a systematic
search but they try to give
as fair as possible of an overview of a
subject
they might do systematic reviews or
meta-analyses we talk about those all
the time
they might publish experimental research
where you
recruit samples split them up do an
intervention etc
but like you know normal science [ __ ]
like that's what gets published in most
journals
what medical hypotheses is for
is basically to float ideas where
there's
uh definitely not enough solid evidence
for a systematic
review and meta-analysis and really
there isn't even enough
solid evidence to do a narrative review
it is exactly what it sounds like it is
a journal for hypotheses
uh if an idea is getting put in medical
hypotheses
instead of just some standard journal
it is fundamentally because there is
not yet enough rigorous evidence to
support the idea being put forth it's
a hypothesis not a theory so that's what
the journal's for
um and so like yeah there's some pretty
wacky stuff that gets published in there
and that's fine because like sometimes
science is advanced by wacky ideas
so that that's not a problem with the
journal itself
you just need to be aware of it when you
see a paper is published in medical
hypotheses like you
should evaluate it with a separate set
of criteria
and just a lot more skepticism than you
than you would to evaluate
ideas put forth in most other journals
the other thing to note specifically
with regards to the article itself
is uh you know i briefly summarized the
claims it was putting forth you wear a
mask
uh it's going to cause respiratory
acidosis and then
a bunch of scary things will happen
downstream from
said respiratory acidosis so that that's
the argument it's putting forth
that is the hypothesis mask acidosis
bad [ __ ] like that's the that's the
train of logic
it was using um and so you know
clearly if you want to be able to make
that point and make it well
you need to make sure you have good
support for the
initial claim that wearing a mask will
cause respiratory acidosis which might
then cause other scary stuff
so i i encountered someone sharing this
study in the wild
and i was like oh this is interesting
let me look into it
and so you know once i identified the
argument they were trying to make i was
like okay
let's check out the sources they're
using to support this argument
and for their core claim that wearing a
mask
causes respiratory acidosis they cited
four sources three of them were
textbooks that didn't provide page
numbers
um i actually own one of the textbooks
and i uh checked out the chapter on
respiratory physiology
and confirmed that it didn't say
anything about
the effects of wearing a mask on on
respiratory acidosis uh basically just
said like if you hypoventilate
uh respiratory acidosis will occur
so uh i'm assuming that the textbooks
don't have like strong support for that
and in terms of original research those
are tertiary sources
in terms of primary is cited to support
that claim there was exactly one study
and it was in in-stage renal patients
uh undergoing um
uh what a dialysis yeah yeah uh
undergoing dialysis
wearing in 95s so you know
your kidney's very important for acid
base
balance acid-base regulation uh
it's it's very possible that in stage
renal patients
presently undergoing dialysis
maybe bad things would happen if they
were in 95
24 7. uh they there was a primary source
to back up that claim
yeah you can't generalize especially
when you're dealing with [ __ ] at
[ __ ] acid base balance stuff you
can't generalize from
in-stage renal patients to the entire
goddamn population
you can't do that yeah they have a
condition
that affects their ability to regulate
blood ph
uh so anyway uh that
that was the only shred of primary
literature to actually back up the claim
so in addition to you know maybe needing
to be a little bit more skeptical
because it was published in medical
hypotheses
there are gradations of stuff that are
published in medical hypotheses like
some
sometimes you uh support your argument
really well
sometimes you don't support your
argument well at all even by the
standards of medical hypotheses
it was an exceptionally poorly and
weakly argued and sourced paper
uh well i've got an update for you i've
got an update for you
so props to elsevier they act it's
already retracted on the site
and they actually rare one of the rare
occasions they gave a good
explanation for it so point number one a
broader review of the existing evidence
clearly shows that approved max approved
masks
are effective in the prevention of covet
19. point number two
the manuscript uh misquotes and
selectively cites
uh references numbers 16 17 25 and 26
all misquoted uh table one
uh they just said all the data in the
table is unverified
and there are several speculative
statements
[Laughter]
so like
[Laughter]
so like that's the thing though it's not
like he like
said hey i tell you what if you look at
this body of literature at just the
right angle it's just like dude it was
just
really bad stuff yeah so anyway
it it's very disappointing that
like so for example
table one all the data in the table is
unfair
unverified and there are several
speculative statements
references 16 17 25 26 are all misquoted
uh you know some of these comments just
simply lack face validity
glad to see it in the retraction notice
but where was it in the reviewer
comments
yeah if they are allegedly helpful i
mean
you you don't want to get me on my
peer-review rant no
but anyway yeah so that was just uh a
trend that
is becoming more common is like you know
all the big brain experts say sure
put it in a journal and then like
literally anybody on twitter who
is like awake when they're reading uh
the headline tweeted is like oh well
that's not true
and then there's a big stink and
eventually sometimes a retraction
you know another area where this
happened this is a
constantly evolving situation
so
mercola who was recently uh
the good doctor yeah he recently was
honored
on the mount rushmore of disinformation
even some some some people put out this
thing it was called the disinformation
dozen it was like the 12 people who were
putting out the
the most and worst disinformation
related to
vaccines yeah like 12 accounts were
uh were putting out information
that accounted for 65 of the total
shares of misinformation related to
covet on social media
yeah so mercola was featured on that
list of 12.
uh you might know his work from pubmed
the peer-reviewed literature
[Laughter]
uh he recently published a paper uh that
that made a number of claims about
vitamin d and you know specifically in
relation
to coven 19. well
though you know he also made a lot of
claims about
vitamin d and covent 19 on his website
on his blog
in articles and the food and drug
administration
was not excited about his content on his
personal website so
the fda sent him a public letter uh that
flagged
some content uh
relating vitamin d to covid 19
risk and uh so the fda was like bro you
you're not allowed to have this stuff in
the places you have it on your blog
uh and so the update today you you sent
me
he he announced on his article
or on his website that he was removing
all those articles
and uh the man the line that stuck out
to me though is that he was like
and i'm going to remove my peer-reviewed
paper on this
topic from my website
but as far as i know it's still
available on pubmed
still available in the journal which is
a pretty wild thing
and that's all i have to say about that
yeah so
one one thing to point out like to
to put a fine point on this yeah mercola
removed the study from hosting it on his
website but it is still
in a journal that that means
the journal is is nutrients by the way
in an mdpi journal
that means that mercola's website
at least in this instance has higher
editorial standards than nutrients
so that's not just any blog that's
[ __ ] joseph mercola's blog
which is incredible um this is a very
abridged version of my peer review rant
uh a very cool thing about science
is that you know we're interested in
quantifying things we want to know if
things work or not if a new supplement
comes on the market
you say hey let's do a
placebo-controlled trial to see if this
supplement does anything
so you know if peer review is one of the
things
that's a cornerstone of the scientific
process that is supposed to be able to
separate the wheat from the chaff
and improve the quality of of articles
before they're published
ideally you'd want to be able to
quantify does this work and if so
how well um no one really thought to do
that until somewhat recently i'm
blanking on the guy's name but he was
the longtime editor-in-chief
of the british medical journal very
prestigious journal
uh and he he kind of got a hunch that
peer review wasn't working that well
and so once he stepped down as
editor-in-chief of the british medical
journal he made it his
you know scientific mission to do a
little meta science and study
how well does peer review work and the
cliff notes are
not great um but i think it's also worth
noting
how peer review as we currently conceive
of it became a thing
so the science existed a long time
before
peer review um they used to call it
refereeing
and it used to be that uh
journals were purely refereed by the by
their editor-in-chief
uh for the most part um so
you know the editor-in-chief would be
someone who was like a world-leading
expert
in whatever field the journal was
publishing stuff in and so like
they could tell for themselves like hey
is this good stuff is it not
uh but then basically you know the scope
of journals widened
the total number of articles submitted
increased and so
uh they started needing to bring in
additional people from time to time to
look at some articles that
you know might be outside uh the realm
of expertise for the editor-in-chief
or you know just to get a second opinion
on it but for a long time it still
wasn't a super super common practice
uh a famous example of this is one of
einstein's papers i believe the one
where uh the the the
paper that talked about the theory of
special relativity
he submitted it to a journal and the
editor-in-chief was like
ah you know this seems pretty cool but i
really need to send it out for a second
opinion
uh when einstein heard that he'd never
been peer reviewed before
because most people at the time never
got peer reviewed
and he was insulted so much that he
retracted his submission
and submitted to another journal because
he was like [ __ ] you dude
like i submitted to this journal because
i thought you knew enough [ __ ] to be
able to review this
but it if if you and your dumb ass can't
review it
and you think you need a second opinion
i'm just gonna submit it somewhere
else that's a that's a loose paraphrase
no that's a quote i believe
but yeah so it wasn't common um
and then uh you know 20th century rolls
along
science starts becoming more and more
politicized
and in the united states uh congress
got uh
you know not super pleased with the
scientific establishment
and were proposing congressional
oversight of scientific publishing
um which to be clear i would not be
a fan of uh and
scientists also weren't a fan of that
and so
in an effort to try to make science seem
uh more neutral and less political uh
they basically said like hey
you know we're we're gonna bring on
independent experts to review
all of the stuff getting published uh
going to call it peer review and it's
going to be great
and that was enough to get congress off
the back of
major scientific publishing in america
um
and you know it wasn't completely
unheard of by then like in the 1920s
very few papers were refereed
when this was happening i believe it was
the 70s like more papers were being
refereed
but it wasn't as it wasn't as
common and it wasn't as regimented as it
is currently but
that's when they basically said like
okay we're gonna institute this formal
system of peer review uh so
please don't do congressional oversight
of all scientific publishing
uh and so congress was like okay cool
but it's worth noting
that uh the incarnation of peer review
as we currently have it
it wasn't a system where a bunch of
scientists got together and said okay
let's test out
several ideas to try to make the
published research
as good as possible except all the good
papers none of the bad papers and
improve
manuscripts as much as possible before
publishing it wasn't
there wasn't a process like that uh it
was basically just
a spur of the moment stop gap
measure to say how can we get congress
to stop breathing down our throats
uh and it worked and we've just stuck
with it um
so yeah peer review is trash it really
is
uh but i said that would be the short
version of my peer review rant but that
was like
this 80 version but yeah i guess to
to wrap up my conclusion of that segment
i i just find it a little bit
counter intuitive that a lot of people
present peer review as like oh well
we'll
check all the important stuff and make
sure it's good enough to call science
but
lately it seems like it's completely
inverted and
people just publish stuff and then the
general public who
honestly lacks the expertise to really
dig into the details is like
uh this clearly isn't very good is it
and they're like all right fine well you
know we'll have to retract it then
uh so keep your eye out for that don't
just because someone has a pubmed link
that seems to support their point
unfortunately
uh it requires a little more digging
before we
accept that at face value uh okay greg
there are a number of questions for you
here do you want to go ahead and just uh
knock out some of these q a questions
i'm removing the one i had for you
because it's
simply a waste of time but uh now i'm
curious what was it
it was very literally a waste of time
i'll tell you about it later
uh all right yeah so why don't you go
ahead and knock out some of these q and
a's so that the people will be informed
yeah let's do it so uh question from
tommy
d stefano i believe from facebook uh
by the way if you want to ask questions
for the podcast
uh we don't really look at the google
form that much anymore
uh before we record i throw a thread up
uh in the facebook group that is
stronger by science community and on the
subreddit
that is reddit.com r slash
stronger by science and those are the
best places to ask your question so
anyway
tommy i believe from facebook asks
is training for strength and hypertrophy
simultaneously really as useless as some
people make it out to be
either in the same body parts are
different say hypertrophy
upper body strength lower body on the
same days or different days etc
more so for recreational intermediate
lifters
so basically asking uh you know some
people say that it's
a waste of time to try to simultaneously
train for
strength and hypertrophy uh are they
correct
my answer to that is no uh and i kind of
want to know
who who says it's useless to strength to
train for strength and hypertrophy at
the same time
um so i first to approach this from
a hypertrophy perspective because my
answer there is shorter
um you know if you're training
to uh peak strength in
you know a few weeks or whatever so
you're training with
really heavy near max loads that are
probably going to cause quite a bit of
stress
and will significantly limit
how much per session training volume you
can do
yeah that will probably limit your
rates of muscle growth uh but also
you know that that doesn't need to be
you don't need a ton of that to train
for strength like
unless you're a very very highly trained
strength athlete already
you can probably get away with just
doing like three or four weeks of that
every
four to six months or something and
mostly just trying to get big and like
you will get stronger in the process
most of the time you're just doing pure
hypertrophy training so you know
doing a little specific strength work on
a hypertrophy program
shouldn't negatively impact hypertrophy
training that much
uh you know maybe it would if you're
you know nearing your absolute genetic
muscular limits but for
99 of people like nah that'll be fine as
far as strength goes
uh in terms of long-term strength
development
i think you should be doing a lot of
hypertrophy training
uh you know you will be able to contract
your muscles harder if you build a lot
of contractile proteins uh which means
doing some hypertrophy training
uh so you know when i think strength
training i think
you know you're doing again depending on
if you're trying to maintain weight to
stay in a weight class
your your level of development you know
you will definitely need to be doing
some very heavy lower volume highly
specific strength work
but you should be doing a lot of
hypertrophy work a lot of the time
again especially tommy's asking about
recreational intermediate lifters yeah
if you're trying to maximize strength
development
you absolutely need to be doing some
hypertrophy training
uh and building muscle
as long as you don't just get super
super out of practice
with low rep
high load specific strength skills
strength is going to go up so i think
for most people
a very very reasonable way to approach
training you can go one of two ways for
simultaneous
hypertrophy and strength development
either you can just do a hypertrophy
program and work some heavy singles in
from time to time and we're not talking
you know true one rep max attempts but
like you know
hit a single around 90 92
from time to time that's heavy enough
that it will help you
maintain and build skill with really
heavy near max loads
and then you're just trying to get big
and you will get stronger and
you know a couple heavy singles from
time to time
uh again not true one rep maxes
that's not going to impact your recovery
enough to really
have any meaningful impact on the sorts
of volumes you can handle for
hypertrophy training
so that's one way you could approach it
another way you could approach it is
kind of a
block periodization approach or an or a
linear periodization approach
and basically you know like uh three
quarters of your training blocks will be
kind of
uh lower load higher to moderate rep
hypertrophy style
training uh and you know if you have
strength in the back of your mind maybe
you're
kind of keeping that on the more on the
5 to 10 reps per set range instead of
like
8 to 15 or something like that so maybe
like
slightly on the heavy end of the
quote-unquote typical
hypertrophy range uh but you you know
train like that
probably 75 percent of the time and then
uh
every fourth block or so work in a more
specific strength block so you're doing
hypertrophy training most of the year
uh but still doing some blocks to focus
on strength development
both of those two approaches will be
great
both long term and and really short term
too
for both strength and hypertrophy again
for most people who aren't already
highly elite highly specialized athletes
in one of those two pursuits
uh second question from matt cincotta
uh oh this was one of the ones on the
the outline for the last episode that i
didn't get to
and i was very excited about it uh hey
greg and trex
you don't need to address questions
about uh
biomechanics to trex uh hope you're
doing well
i've seen it suggested that the study
quote effect of barbell weight on the
structure of the flat bench press
close quote by kroll and golus suggest
that when you get towards max weight in
the bench press the triceps become the
prime movers
this is used as justification to focus
on variations and accessory movements
for the tries
rather than the picks do you see
validity in this claim
and how does other research on this
topic support or
refute this claim uh and yeah so i i was
excited to see the study because i
actually do have a pretty strong take
about this
uh so first to start with uh
what happened in the kroll and goalless
study
basically what they did is they had
people work up to one rep max
bench presses in ten percent increments
so uh they did a set at seventy percent
a set at eighty percent
a set of ninety percent and a set at one
hundred percent of their one rep max
uh and they looked at muscle emg for
uh the pecs anterior anterior delts
and the long head of the triceps uh
in all of those lifts and what they
found
is that the increase in emg
from the moderate loads like 70 80
percent of one rm
the increase in emg from those lighter
loads to
maximal loads the increase was the
largest in the triceps
basically no increase at all in the pecs
uh and a
notable increase in the anterior
deltoids but not nearly as large as the
triceps
and so you you look at that and you see
like oh okay
as the loads go up triceps emg ramps up
a ton uh therefore you know at max
loads your triceps become the prime
movers uh seems logical enough
but uh i think it's misleading first i
don't necessarily know that you could
make those claims from emg in the first
place but
even if we assume that you could i think
the important thing to note
is that they were measuring emg in the
long head of the triceps
the long head of the triceps is a
biarticular muscle
meaning it crosses both the elbow and
the shoulder
and one thing to note about biarticular
muscles
is that when you're performing exercises
where
one of the functions of the muscle would
be quote unquote beneficial for exercise
performance
and one of the other functions would be
quote unquote negative
for performance of that exercise uh the
nervous system
tends to de-emphasize recruitment of
that bi-articular muscle
so a great example of that is the rectus
femoris in the squat
so rectus femoris activation in the
squat
not particularly high rectus femoris is
a quad muscle so it's a knee extensor
which is a great for squatting but your
rectus femoris is also a hip flexor
and in the squat you're trying to extend
your hips and so
especially with lower loads your vast
eye muscles your vastus lateralis
medialis intermedius very very active
contributing a lot to the squat
your rectus femoris isn't that active
but
activity does ramp up as you approach
near max
loads i think the same thing is
happening with the long head of the
triceps and the bench press
so it is an elbow extensor which is good
uh but it's also a shoulder extensor
which is bad
you're doing shoulder flexion when
you're bench pressing so i think
basically your
your nervous system isn't
extra emphasizing the long head of your
triceps as you approach a max
i think what they were what they were
finding was that your nervous system is
de-emphasizing recruitment of the long
head of your triceps when you're
benching lower loads and so since it's
de-emphasizing long head of triceps
recruitment with low loads you see that
large
relative increase when you work up to a
max uh
and you know we don't just have to base
this on emg we have longitudinal
evidence
showing that bench press training uh is
not particularly
great for growing the long head of the
triceps so there was a study by
brandow and colleagues that will be
linked in the show notes
it came out a year or two ago pretty
recent but it was looking at growth
in all uh all three heads of the triceps
after bench press training
found that the bench press was really
really good for growing the lateral head
of the triceps
but caused basically no growth in the
long head of the triceps so
basically i think the kroll and goalless
study was finding that
you know at 70 of 1rm long head of your
triceps really not doing much
uh but then your nervous system does
call on it a little bit more
when you're actually attempting a one
rep max bench press
um so i think a better study to look
to look at so basically
all said and told you know long head of
your tricep
not a particularly important muscle for
the bench press the lateral head of your
triceps
is the tricep head that's primarily
doing tricep [ __ ] in the bench press
that's that's going to be your primary
elbow extensor
so with that in mind uh a better study
to look at
is uh dr michael duffy's
dissertation study which will also be
linked in the show notes
um a paper from this research project
was published but i don't think
the data i'm about to reference did wind
up getting published but you know it's
there in the dissertation
cleared the committee one thing to note
a committee review
generally more stringent than peer
review
so do without what you will uh but
anyway so
uh duffy looked at
basically the same thing as kroll and
golus
so changes in pecs anterior delts and
lateral head of the triceps emg
as weights increased from sub-maximal to
maximal
uh and basically found that in in all
three of those muscles
the uh increase in emg when going from
sub maximal to maximal loads
uh was pretty similar for all three
muscles so
you know you didn't see a
disproportionate increase
in the lateral head of the triceps emg
as loads increased it was basically the
same as it was for the delts and
and the pecs um so anyway
i think basically the crow and goal of
study was just confirming what we know
about biarticular muscles
that uh they're not generally
particularly active
in compound exercises with relatively
low loads but
you know they do contribute a little bit
more at max loads i i think that's what
they were finding they weren't
necessarily finding
that your triceps become the prime mover
uh
at max loads i think it was just an
artifact
of them looking at the long head of the
triceps instead of the lateral head
all right moving on jer chapman asks
this is bizarre but it popped into my
head today are there types of muscles
that are resistant to hypertrophy
could you get a jacked tongue if you
apply sufficient volume and load to it
if not are calves made of the same stuff
as tongues
funny serious question okay so
um i'm going out
in left field to answer this one uh
i think tongues can get pretty huge
actually
this set you on a collision course with
a great deal of tongue-related research
uh i witnessed as you kind of chased
further and further down that
that hole yeah yeah yeah so um
one thing to note about tongues tongues
are a lot bigger than you think they are
uh just google image search uh
tongue muscle anatomy or something like
that i think when people think tongue
they think uh you know a little fan
shaped thing
within the the normal confines of your
mouth
but no your tongue is a big ass muscle
uh
it originates on your hyoid bone which
is kind of like
near your adam's apple if you're a dude
um
so like it originates way down there has
a big
thick muscle body and you know the the
part of it you see
that you can stick out of your mouth
that is proverbially speaking just the
tip of the iceberg so it's a very big
muscle
um and i
so this question got me to look at uh
can tongue muscle hypertrophy
occur and basically like do tongues vary
in size because like yeah i
didn't expect to find uh like a
resistance training study where you
apply
progressive overload to the tongue so
first off i just wanted to see
can tongues vary in size uh and that led
me
to a body of literature looking at the
causes of sleep apnea so there are
various
uh ideologies of sleep apnea but the
most common is obstructive sleep apnea
and that's where you know something is
blocking
the back of your throat so you can't
breathe particularly while
when when you fall asleep uh and it
turns out
you know there there are various
structures back there that could be at
fault
uh but it seems like probably the
primary one is your tongue
and obesity is a
common risk factor for sleep apnea
one of the things i didn't realize this
blew my [ __ ] mind
you have fat deposits in your tongue i
did not know that i thought tongues were
just 100
lean tissue but no you have fat deposits
in your tongue
and one of the reasons why risk of
obstructive sleep apnea
increases with obesity is that the fat
deposits in your tongue
grow your tongue is physically larger
and it impedes more on the back of your
throat
also um like the the other tissues
around the back of your throat also have
fat deposits so that contributes as well
but
a lot of it seems to be tongue driven so
there was
uh studies looking at uh obese people
who reported
or who had confirmed obstructive sleep
apnea
compared to obese people who didn't and
they basically found
the folks with obstructive sleep apnea
just had bigger [ __ ] tongues than the
one
than the ones that didn't uh and those
tongues had substantially larger fat
deposits so
um that's not related to the answer
to this question at all but it got me
thinking
about steroids because uh obstructive
sleep apnea is also really common
in steroid users and
one of the things that people note is
that a big neck
is uh another thing that's associated
with sleep apnea
and that's always driven me crazy
because i was just thinking about it
like
i know where your [ __ ] trachea is
like having really
thick cervical extensors doesn't really
seem like it should be doing anything to
to block up your trachea so you know
like i i
knew that large necks were associated
with a
risk of obstructive sleep apnea but it
didn't make sense to me like that
connection didn't make sense
and so now now i'm just kind of thinking
that like people with big necks
either probably have a fair amount of
body fat and maybe have
a fat deposition pattern that's kind of
like
head and neck centric where maybe if you
have a lot of fat around your neck
you're also more likely to deposit fat
in the tissues in your throat and also
your tongue
or you know you do a lot of steroids
and if you're doing steroids uh enough
to
to make your neck grow without neck
training maybe that
is inherently causing uh tongue
hypertrophy because like that's another
skeletal muscle
uh and maybe that's what's giving you
sleep apnea
um i couldn't find primary research to
back that up like i couldn't find a
longitudinal study looking at the uh
longitudinal effects of anabolic
steroids on tongue mass or anything like
that
but i did find some uh some
anesthesiology just like kind of best
practices where
they were saying like if someone is
going under and they look really
muscular you should
you should ask them if they're using
steroids because uh
if they are that that is
going to increase their risk of like not
being able to breathe once they go under
so like
you might need to do some other [ __ ] uh
and
specifically with regards to them having
larger tongues
so basically like i don't know all of
that makes me think that
tongues are just like any other muscle
uh they they
probably they probably grow in response
to steroids
uh they they therefore would probably
grow
in response to resistance training i
kind of i kind of think that other than
having way more degrees of freedom
they're
they're just really not that different
from other skeletal muscles
um so yeah i think
skeletal muscles can get big and
therefore your calves can probably also
get big
ultimately this comes back to the calves
uh
but yeah the the stuff i was reading
about sleep apnea blew my mind i had
i had no idea your tongue came into it
but a lot of it seems to be
pretty tongue-centric oh also another
potential implication of that to be
clear this entire segment including what
i'm about to say
not a doctor don't take this as medical
advice all standard disclaimers apply
uh but one of the questions i get asked
a lot is like hey
you know having a big neck that seems to
be a
risk factor for obstructive sleep apnea
so like if i try to do some neck
training and get a big neck is that
going to give me sleep apnea
to be clear i don't know i'm not saying
it will
i'm not saying it won't
but if this seems to be a very
tongue-centric thing
and not necessarily related to so like
if neck size isn't the causative factor
if it's more like correlative for other
things like if a big neck is
indicative of fat deposits in the head
neck
throat region or if it's indicative of
steroid use which is causing tongue
hypertrophy but the neck size itself
isn't necessarily inherently
because of obstructive sleep apnea
if that is the case again not medical
advice not saying it is
not saying it's not but if that's the
case then uh
neck training itself per se uh
should be fine i would think anyway
a lot of stuff about tongues man uh
just to reiterate google image search
tongue anatomy they're [ __ ] huge
um okay moving on
david meverden uh asks
glucosamine and chondroitin a good
supplement for older lifters
will it prevent or repair any joint wear
and tear
so that's a good question and i
first came across a 2010
systematic review and meta-analysis uh
from
wandel and colleagues and uh
the basic conclusion is uh
this is a quote compared with placebo
glucosamine chondroitin and their
combination do not reduce joint pain
or have an impact on narrowing of joint
space health authorities and health
insurers should not cover the cost of
these preparations
blah blah blah so basically it found
that
when reviewing all of the literature
that existed in 2010
didn't seem like glucosamine and
chondroitin
really did much of anything uh however
i found a uh a study that
uh or also a meta-analysis that just for
whatever reason didn't
uh show up as highly in the searches uh
barely came across this
almost stopped looking before i found it
uh but a more recent meta-analysis from
2018
uh from zoo and colleagues uh
looked at 26 articles describing
30 distinct trials um
and so basically it did find that
glucosamine did
some stuff and chondroitin did some
other stuff
um so uh the conclusion was given the
effectiveness
of uh blah blah blah one second
glucosamine showed effect on stiffness
outcome
uh chondroitin is more effective than
placebo on relieving pain and improving
physical function
uh not many studies looking at the
combination therapy
most of the studies that looked at both
together didn't find significant effects
but
there were fewer combination studies
than just glucosamine or
just chondroitin so unless they
have inhibitory effects on each other
you know maybe they'd be more effective
in tandem but basically
state of the literature as of 2010 is uh
not enough evidence to say that they do
much of anything by 2018
few more studies had been published a
little more statistical power
when looking at a wide range of clinical
outcomes
chondroitin seems to have a small effect
on pain and physical function and
glucosamine seems to have a small effect
for reducing stiffness neither are
particularly notable
so my
i mean my my number one advice is if
you're asking about this
in relation to pain
or function issues uh talk to a physical
therapist or a doctor
um but just my read of the literature as
it is now
you know they they seem to have either
no side effects or very very mild side
effects
uh maybe some gi discomfort if you use
really high dosages
uh and they may have a small beneficial
effect for reducing stiffness
uh decreasing pain a little bit uh but
don't
don't expect a night and day difference
from them so you know
may not do anything if they do have an
effect it's probably positive but
probably fairly small one thing related
to
uh that meta-analysis i noticed in the
title it seems to be
specifically related to osteoarthritis
patients
oh yeah yeah that that is worth noting
uh
so yeah the the evidence that shows
efficacy is in osteoarthritis patients
um so so david was asking about older
lifters
uh i mean most people when they get old
enough they
have osteoarthritis in at least one or
two joints
so yeah in that context uh
you know older lifter and lifter with
osteoarthritis
yeah there's a lot of overlap there uh
but yeah
you're preaching to the choir i'm in my
30s for god's sakes that
that is true but no that is worth noting
um
i i wasn't able to find much evidence
that it does
stuff for people who don't have
osteoarthritis but
if you do maybe it has uh a small
positive effect
all right uh not a llama ama
asks uh indicators or
kind of ask kind of statement uh what
are the indicators that one needs
extra conditioning for strength and
hypertrophy
uh so i
if you asked me this a few years ago i
probably would have given a different
answer
um but i think the
uh i so i think the um
general sign is just that you've reached
a point where you need
more volume to continue making progress
than you can
either comfortably get through in a
training session or that you can recover
from so
to be clear uh i think that in general
your best approach is to start with
you know fairly low to moderate levels
of training volume
see where that gets you uh and then
increase as needed so you know not just
jumping to the highest levels of
training volume that you can survive
straight from the jump but you know if
your training volume is gradually
drifting up over time
uh and you eventually reach the point
where you're not making more gains and
you're having
real real difficulty getting through
your training sessions or recovering
from them
maybe that's an indication that you need
to do some conditioning but then the
question is
what kind of conditioning should you do
and i used to
think uh you know keep training how you
want but like yeah maybe
maybe throw some low intensity cardio
into the mix and in general i
am still a fan of very low intensity
cardio and by that i mean
just going for walks pretty regularly
it's good for a lot of stuff
good vibes get your step count up not
die young
all good things but in terms of actual
training outcomes
i kind of think the best approach for
most people is just kind of to
take a step down the intensity ladder so
if you're having trouble tolerating the
volume you need
of heavy lower volume strength training
and you want to do some conditioning
that will improve that
if you're used to doing triples just do
some sets of
five to eight for a while uh that will
be
more total tonnage it will be more
metabolically stressful it's still
specific to what you're trying to do
and that will that will cause a
conditioning response where
when you go back to triples they'll be
easier you'll be able to do more without
getting as tired
and if you're having issues with
hypertrophy training you know you're
doing sets of eight to twelve
and you're you're having issues with the
volume there
uh take another step down the intensity
ladder you know instead of sets of eight
to twelve
do sets of twelve to fifteen maybe [ __ ]
around and go up to 20 to 25 sometime
uh exact same principle so
you know you're gonna get more reps uh
there's going to be a greater metabolic
cost per set
uh it's it's gonna be tough it is
especially for leg training it's gonna
suck pretty bad
uh but that is specific conditioning
work
and i mean in that case it will still be
a great direct stimulus for hypertrophy
so
you're not even having to put your main
goal on the back burner while you're
doing it
uh you know if if you get to the point
that you can
pretty comfortably do you know four sets
of 15 instead of four sets of eight
when you go back to four sets eight it's
gonna be a lot easier
so yeah i think for most people uh the
the type of conditioning that you know
shouldn't be the only tool in your
toolkit but should be the first
tool you reach for in your toolkit most
of the time is just continuing to
train basically like you have been but
just taking a step down the intensity
ladder
and that will be good specific
conditioning work for most folks
okay uh in this this last one um
you know i'll read it and we can see if
we want to talk about it or not
sure um this is a question that i feel
like we could do
half an episode on getting really into
the research i have not done any
literature search for this at all i
don't think trex has either
so we're gonna read this question and
just give our vibes based answer to it
so brightredspud asks how important is
good food really
it seems like i often hear vague
comments that good nutrition is
important
guidelines all suggest unprocessed
grains and lots of vegetables
i cook my own meals but it's usually
best effort vegetables and filling out
my calories with ice cream and cookies
so what am i actually leaving on the
table 0.69 percent of my possible
strength gains
10-year loss of expected life due to
some terrible vitamin deficiency
induced by eating too much rice while
doubling the amount of vegetables i eat
produce a profound experience like
discovering eight hours of sleep per
night
so yeah basically just asking like food
quality
what do is it good and if so how good
that's tough like you said we could
probably do a probably do like half an
episode on it
because we could talk about process
versus unprocessed foods or
i guess more accurately the degree of
processing
with foods fiber intake micronutrient
intake
specific sugars that might find their
way into your diet
the importance of the food matrix
outside of just the
nutrients that make up the food uh you
you could look at that
on a variety of different levels uh
but what's your initial vibe i do have
kind of a guiding statement
but but i want to hear your vibes first
uh
i mean so i i think it's going to depend
on
two things primarily i think
so i'm thinking about this purely in
terms of strength and hypertrophy
you know i i do think it's pretty clear
that
you know eating vegetables and mental
minimally processed foods
yeah probably a pretty good idea for
longevity uh but in terms of
uh like strength and hypertrophy
outcomes
i think that uh it depends at least in
part on
generally how healthy are you just
in general so uh you know
age is going to be a component of that
uh
body composition is gonna be a component
of that um
you know and like what else like
when you when you talk about eating like
bad stuff what do you mean
you know so are you talking like
mcdonald's cheeseburgers
are you talking like you know i'm gonna
slam six beers a night
and uh cook all my food in pure trans
fat you know so there's
um well so i guess that's three things
so like
when you talk about eating good versus
bad is it like generally decent but
more or less veggies or you know is it
some like extreme
worst possible diet type scenario uh so
i i think like
you know if you're eating generally okay
but not a ton of vegetables
you're generally healthy and active and
fairly young
otherwise uh and the last
thing if you're if you aren't
dealing with like some very specific
nutrient deficiency so
you know if for whatever reason your
diet's just purely devoid of zinc
or something like that uh that that's a
cofactor and a lot of
important chemical reactions involved in
metabolism
if you have a zinc deficiency that's
going to be some bad news
for performance and and probably
hypertrophy and body comp as well
but you know basically if if you don't
have some sort
of major nutrient deficiency if you're
fairly young and healthy
and your idea of a not great diet is
still like kind of decent but like maybe
not as many fruits and vegetables as
would be ideal i think you'll generally
be pretty fine
and not really like i think you'll feel
better if you eat more fruits and
vegetables but in terms of
strength and hypertrophy outcomes i
really don't think you'll be missing out
on
much if any but if you start tweaking
some of those assumptions like
maybe you're a little bit older uh
dealing with just like a higher baseline
level of inflammation
uh maybe the quote unquote bad diet
is really bad and we're talking about
cleaning that up a lot
or if you have some sort of major
nutrient deficiency that a more
well-rounded diet would correct
then then i do think it would have uh
potentially a pretty large
impact on training outcomes yeah
i i largely agree with that i think the
the one additional statement i would add
to it is that my perspective on this
is not that bad foods are
you know quote unquote bad foods are
inherently deleterious i think the
biggest threat of having a bad diet
is more the lack of good things rather
than the introduction of bad things
uh in a lot of cases so if you're
eating foods in a you know
subjectively bad diet that is displacing
important nutrients uh then that's where
we start to run into issues but like
a great example is you know you think of
uh
you know an endurance athlete for
example
who's got a base diet that's pretty
healthy but they're
uh about to do a pretty high volume
phase of their training
at a certain point it's just like we
need to supplement your diet with
calories
and so adding in foods that are
hedonically
very enjoyable and calorie dense and
don't have a lot of micronutrients
it's not necessarily a bad thing because
we're just trying to supplement a diet
with
some form of calories that doesn't feel
like a chore to consume
so when it comes to any discussion about
food quality or diet quality i always
like to
make sure we kind of frame it and say
that like unless you're eating just
absurd amounts of you know ethanol and
trans fats like you said
it's not that we're worried about the
introduction
of calorically dense foods it's that
we're worried about the absence of the
good stuff we need to make sure that the
good stuff's in there
and that's more from a that's more from
a health and well-being perspective than
necessarily from a making gains
perspective
because like you said as long as you
don't have any major deficiencies
and and stuff like that uh
i mean i know what i ate like when i was
19. and i made plenty of gains
and it was not a vegetable heavy diet so
like i i
could say from personal experience if
you're hitting the weight hard and
eating plenty of calories plenty of
protein
and you're not just critically deficient
in any particular nutrient
you you can make gains but
you might also like you said feel like
crap uh
but yeah i think we should circle back
to that in the future sometime
and take a take a closer look at some of
the components of that
uh because because we could go on for
quite some time but
i think we are just about out of time
for today's episode so it's probably
time
to play us out and i'm gonna start out
the
segment to play us out here by putting
two things on notice
and putting something on notice
basically means they're on the you know
like wada has the watch list
it's like not banned yet but they're
keeping an eye on it
you're one step away from being put on
blast exactly yeah so if you're on
notice it means that you've captured my
attention for an
unfavorable reason uh and you
are officially on the watch list so
number one
bay leaves total scam i
was so i make soup now for my meal prep
it's like a lentil based soup
it's good stuff i ran out of bay leaves
you know this like 75 dollar container
of bay leaves where you get like four
leaves in it
and i was like oh i'm out of bay leaves
what am i going to do this recipe is
gonna suck oh well
you know i gotta i gotta eat this week
so i make it
didn't notice at all bay leaves do not
do anything
they are a tax that is applied that
purely uh preys on misinformation and
your misunderstanding of what they do
because
they do literally nothing so bae leaves
you're on notice
another uh thing that's on notice in
this case a group of people
uh this was brought to my attention in
the stronger by science facebook group
we've got people who are out there
speeding up the podcast listening to it
at
uh 1.25 1.5
in some cases i think people even said
two times the regular speed
the fastest i saw this 2.6 2.6
and you might be thinking well that's a
silly thing to be upset about but
all i would ask is that people respect
what we put into our art
you know uh as the on-air talent
as the person who writes half the
outline and
notably the person who does all the
post-production
uh every single detail of the podcast
is meticulously planned and thought
through
and stressed over uh pauses are put in
artistically uh the tempo of speech is
important so
it truly is like buying an original
rembrandt or a van gogh and just
coloring over it and saying
i thought it could have used more blue
it is a huge slap in the face
so shame on all those who are listening
to this at a very rapid pace right now
um i feel like i had something else to
say about that but
it has eluded me so time for you to play
us out with whatever you got
yeah so i i also have two things uh so
back by popular demand we're going to
talk about factors that
influence what type of intermittent
fasting you should do
on a recent episode of the podcast we
talked about
different intermittent fasting profiles
based on your myers-briggs
profile this time we're talking about
a much more uh rigorously
validated thing and that is of course
foot shape so um
some of which exist some don't yeah yeah
yeah so uh uh
hopefully we could do do you think you
could uh maybe just like
upload this picture to imgur and put a
imgur link
no but if you upload it to him guru i
can put the link okay
uh shoot me a message to remind me uh
and i i will do
that um so anyway it uh
yeah so apparently you can tell what
type of intermittent fasting you should
do based on how your foot is shaped and
the noteworthy thing here is that i do
not
believe that two of these foot
shapes exist so there's a b
c and d uh and first i'll i'll describe
the real ones so that's b
and c in b uh your
your big toe and your second toe
are about the same length and your third
toe uh
kind of comparable and then your uh
fourth and fifth toe are are shorter
and kind of slope down very normal foot
shape
of these on here that's what mine is
closest to
c also a real foot shape
you have a kind of normal size big toe
your second toe is longer than your big
toe
and then your other three are
progressively shorter from there
uh i i have seen feet that are shaped
like that before
normal foot that's a totally fine foot
to have
um then a and d
don't exist they don't exist in the wild
and also
i'll note if if you look at this image
and you say oh that's how my foot is
shaped i'm going to send
greg a picture as proof don't [ __ ] do
that i'm not a foot guy
foot guys are weird uh also putting foot
guys on notice
that's weird um but a
it's just a [ __ ] 45 degree angle
straight down uh and you know it's it's
not just that the big toe
is the longest followed by the second
toe followed by the third
also like the the metatarsals
are varying in length in a very linear
fashion
uh very disconcerting not good doesn't
exist
it's not real and then d also
bizarre foot i've never seen a foot that
looks like this
a big toe that's probably like three
times longer than all of the rest
and then toes two through five exact
same length
that also that foot doesn't exist it's
not real
um so anyway just to start with
this is [ __ ] they're saying that
there are four distinct foot shapes and
they all
track to a particular intermittent
fasting profile
but right right off the jump only two of
the four
are actual real foot shapes uh and then
you know once you've gotten past that it
is clear that the type of intermittent
fasting you should do
should absolutely be dictated by foot
shape i have no
issue with that whatsoever that's that's
very uh rigorously proven we should get
grant
to talk about that great sizzling friend
of the show yeah yeah but you know
like the the fine science of
dictating uh eating patterns by foot
shape
don't denigrate that by trying to
convince me that
foot shapes exist that don't actually
exist uh
you're not going to get that one by me
yeah so
for people keeping score you want to do
intermittent fasting listen to our
episode with dr grant tinsley who has
done a lot of that research
and then figure out your personality
type and then figure out your foot
shape and that should be all the
information you need perfect
uh and then i think the last thing i
want to go out with
is a podcast recommendation so
there is a podcast that is currently
airing
uh i don't know how many more episodes
they're they're gonna be in the run but
it's
uh it's a limited series so you know
there there will be a finite number of
episodes uh but it's called
operation midnight climax and it
is a story about uh
one part of the cia's attempted mind
control program
uh which you know if if you've done any
reading about the cia
you know about mk ultra so it's it's
like one facet of the mk ultra program
um absolutely insane story
very very riveting audio content
um one thing i will say that's kind of a
negative about it in my book
is that it's like very scripted and
produced
uh and i i tend to prefer uh podcasts
that have
a more casual and conversational tone
uh but the the story itself is wild
and i'm very much enjoying it so far so
you know if you want a non-fitness
related podcast to listen to
uh check out operation midnight climax
it has been
very fun so far so i remembered what i
was going to say
when i was shaming the people that
listen to the podcast at an elevated
speed
uh first of all clearly i'm joking our
episodes are far too long
the idea that anyone's listening at
normal tempo is painful
i'm sure most people speed it up to some
degree uh
but i was we were talking about this the
other day and we get
so many very toxic negative reviews of
people
who miss our sarcasm oh yeah yeah and
we're like
dude how how are you missing the
sarcastic tone
and i think a lot of it has to do with
timing and tempo and
cadence and so that actually helps me
go to sleep at night thinking that less
people truly hate me
and more people hate me due to a simple
misunderstanding because they're
listening
listening to the podcast at a faster
speed so hopefully that's the case
um so if you like the show by the way uh
be sure to rate it give it a good rating
if you don't like the show
uh either don't rate it or make sure the
rating is very funny so that we can
discuss it on the show
uh but i think that does it for this
particular episode we'll be back in a
couple weeks
with another thank you for listening to
the stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified
healthcare professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
[Music]
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you